what's going on guys this is rob and
happy thanksgiving a day early
technically it's not until tomorrow but
if you're anything like me you're going
to be filling your bellies full of food
you're going to get the itis you're
going to get a good night's sleep and
then you're going to wake up bright and
early on friday and try to make it to
those black friday sales i know i am i
got my credit card paid off and
everything i'm ready to max this thing
out i'm gonna be painfully irresponsible
with my financial life on friday
but we are officially here with the
actual main spider-verse event only took
us like a month to get here so all the
lead-up is done right basically all the
lead-up is finished we're in the main
event now the throws of spider-verse we
pick up with peter parker as he is
contacted at 6 a.m by jay jonah jameson
who basically sends him over to
armstrong park and the reason why is
that in armstrong park there's just some
guy out there causing all kinds of
problems and ripping stuff up only for
us to find out that it's more lon now
here's a crazy thing about this right
off the bat peter doesn't recognize him
he doesn't know who he is instead more
lund just kind of taunts in the same way
that he always has and saying like we've
done this on so many earths across the
multiverse you know and it's almost one
of these things where he's like where he
kind of explains who he is and peter's
like i mean i have no idea what you're
talking about we're not even on earth
and in response more lens like i don't
even know why i bother explaining this
when all you guys do is die and then he
in turn just kills spider-man only for
us to find out that this is actually
earth 449. this is an alternate reality
where humanity had basically colonized
the moon and they live on the blue area
of the moon those of you guys who don't
know what that is the blue area of the
moon is the oxygen-rich area of the moon
right where you can really have entire
bases of operations the watchers stayed
there the inhumans lived there
apocalypse the x-men villain had a base
of operations there for a while it's
been used by a lot of people it was
created by the creed when they were
working on creating the inhumans on
earth and it just stayed there ever
since but we end up switching back to
what's basically loom world right this
is earth one this is the base of
operations for the inheritors this is
where these guys operate out of and
again they work directly with or really
control the master weaver now remember
the master weaver is the guy who
basically controls the gateway to
alternate dimensions the way this is
depicted and the way that it's done you
have what's essentially called the web
of life and destiny it's a really overly
convoluted and complicated method of
explaining the idea that the master
weaver can basically allow people or at
least open a portal using the web of
life and destiny to transport anybody to
any universe that's connected to the web
of life and destiny right so it's
literally strands like it looks like a
giant web but each one of these
universes is basically represented as a
strand as part of this web so if you
were to cut away a universe from this
web and remove it then it would be
isolated from the rest of the multiverse
now one of the things that you guys are
also going to notice over the course of
the spider-verse event is that the web
of life and destiny will actually begin
to shrink in size and the reason why is
because remember while the whole of
spider versus taking place the events of
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers are going on so universes are
smashing into each other they're being
destroyed two at a time it's just the
collapse of everything the end of
everything and that's it's a really
really cool depiction by dan slott in
them to actually shrink the web of life
and destiny as the entire events of the
incursions go on showing us that the
multiverse is getting smaller universes
are being destroyed and of course this
leads to more lunch showing up here
after basically consuming spider-man
from earth 449 and he's actually kind of
teased by his brothers and sisters now
that's one of the things to know here is
the inheritor family is pretty prideful
and they're also just dicks but it's
also one of these things where they're
exceedingly arrogant and so far as
they're like we're at the top of the
food chain and in a lot of ways they are
they really really are right they're
arrogant but they can also back it up
right technically they feed or they can
feed on anything that is part of the
animal totem right so any superhero that
represents some aspect of the animal
kingdom black panther spider-man anybody
out there like that they can feed on
those individuals but they prefer to
feed on spiders and in fact they were
directed by their father to feed on
spiders and seemingly nothing else so
we'll actually get a motivation for that
when we're introduced to the father of
the inheritors because i'm gonna tell
you right now man that dude is broken
god he is so op it's nuts how cool he
was but the thing about this is his
family basically knows he avoids earth
616 right he avoids the main marvel
universe and they kind of tease him
about it a little bit and so at the same
time of course you end up having verna
who's basically one of the inheritors
who assembles her hounds in reality this
is dan's slot borrowing heavily from the
events of days of future past and i
would even go as far as to say that
because of the fact that the inheritors
have existed across the multiverse they
probably came across days of future past
those of you guys who don't know how
that whole thing worked with days of
future past as we've talked about before
it was basically when things popped off
the mutants were considered a credible
threat and basically the sentinel
program was activated became self-aware
and then conquered north america and
then basically set its sights on trying
to conquer the world but because
sentinels couldn't be everywhere one of
the things that they did is they created
what were called hounds basically
mutants tasked with tracking down other
mutants rachel summers was one of those
right so now she's in the main mobile
universe as part of jonathan hickman's
x-men run but when she originally
appeared she was initially a hound she
was used by the sentinels and even some
humans before the total sentinel
takeover to basically hunt other mutants
and bring them in and so that's kind of
where this seems to come from as far as
these hounds go what you have is silver
sable you've got fire heart and you've
basically got craven the hunter they
basically help verna track down spider
totems across the multiverse and then
basically help her in her hunt for some
people and even other members of her
family it looks like it's just kind of
cheating to a degree that the nature of
like hunting the spider totems should be
done it's like a solo act but they've
sort of moved beyond this being a sort
of rite of testing or right of approval
and instead moved into the direction of
like now it's just for fun right it's
just for sport just kind of what they do
and so at that point when when verna
goes on her mission to find her spiders
you end up switching over to peter
parker in the main marvel universe right
of course again he's met by the arrival
of silk we talked about her before the
two of them can't stop banging there's a
reason for that there's a really really
really cool reason for that the
hierarchy and the role the spider totems
play those are guys who are a little
curious or a little confused about the
nature of spider totems that will all
become clear as we progress through the
story so don't worry i'm not going to
leave you hanging just kind of hang with
me for a minute but it's one of these
things where cindy moon actually pitches
the idea that because she's becoming
more capable in terms of her role as a
spider that peter parker should like
leave new york or even just leave earth
and like go to the moon or go somewhere
else right it doesn't really matter i
mean she's half joking here but she's
also half serious because as long as the
two of them operate in the same vicinity
they will be attracted to each other
there are hormones and really their role
within the nature of the spider totem
hierarchy will bring them together and
they will ultimately end up just
ignoring everything and just procreating
like rabbits again right but what you
end up finding out here is that
following the events of spider island
those you guys remember that when he had
like the you know everybody on on the
island of new york literally turning
into a spider that one of the things
that dr octopus had done when he was
superior spider-man as he had largely
formed his own kind of spider army what
you ended up getting was actually a
whole bunch of these criminals who just
stole these suits in tech they pretended
to work for spider-man and then robbed a
bank which is actually not the most
unintelligent thing to do it's a pretty
good plan now of course peter parker and
cindy moon catch up to them but while
peter parker is trying to apprehend
these guys suddenly he's met by jessica
drew spider woman as well as anya
corazon and then miguel o'hara now
jessica drew most of you guys know from
from marvel comics you guys have heard
of her right she's spider woman she's an
avenger that kind of a thing miguel
o'hara we just talked about in the
previous video on your craziness
somebody who's actually worth discussing
here so anyaka razon's not really an
actual spider person meaning she wasn't
really bitten by a radioactive spider
per se she's actually part of a group
called the spider society which has
existed for a long long time so if the
inheritors hunt down spider totems and
then kill them and consume their energy
then the spider society is the
antithesis of that they actually worship
spider totems and so while they wouldn't
necessarily attack anybody out there who
is a quote unquote villain they will
fight anybody who is considered to be a
threat to anybody who is an actual
spider person now the other thing about
this is that for the spider society to
be effective they had what are called
hunters which were basically their
soldiers and they were individuals who
were imbued with what was essentially
mysticism that gave them the powers of a
spider and that's where anyaka raisin
comes from initially it was believed
that she was supposed to be a hunter
that ended up changing later on in
marvel comics they actually switched it
to a new person instead of her but for
time she was pretty cool and pretty
popular the overall gist here is that
there's all kinds of members of the
spider community here more so than that
you get billy braddock right so spider
uk which we've talked about him we've
covered him mayday parker we covered her
spider-ham is here like it's just this
enormous coming together of all these
different spider characters now here's
the thing to understand peter parker
doesn't know what's going on with all
the different spider-man being hunted
across the multiverse he has no idea
that's happening he doesn't even know
that like the entire spider army is
being assembled remember peter parker's
just got his body back from when dr
octopus had it as superior spider-man
and so where doctor octopus superior
spider-man was assembling this great big
huge spider army this all happened
without peter parker being aware of what
was going on he initially thinks it's
mysterio that mysterio is messing with
his head he's using some kind of trick
or something like that to do spider-man
spider sense and to basically send all
this stuff in a disarray and make it
look like this kind of thing is going on
which really speaks volumes about the
character of mysterio because he could
do it right that's just how good he is
now of course this leads to mayday
parker revealing her identity and
basically telling peter no right like we
are actually here it's not some kind of
an illusion you know me you've met me
before everything's cool essentially we
really do have a big thing going on we
need you here right and that's when
spider uk is like you faced the threat
before like it's more long like more lun
is who we have to deal with now where
peter thinks that morlan is coming back
the response to spider uk is no it's not
mourillan who's coming here it's his
brother deimos and that's when peter
begins to learn more lund's got
relatives remember up until this point
this moment right here peter only
thought it was morlan he thought that
was it right morlun was like just the
inheritor that like ezekiel sims the
person who warned peter parker about
morlun in the early days of j michael
cerzinski's run when all of this really
began if we're being honest with
ourselves uh that there wasn't really a
whole lot of discussion about the
extended family of morlan it was really
just more lon is hunting you peter make
sure you stay safe because he'll take
your energy and kill you right that's
basically what he'll do and so just kind
of peter fleeing for his life against
more lawn than eventually fighting him
and then killing him a handful of times
and so this is the first time peter
learns that there's actually a huge
inheritor family and there's more than
just more land that there's actually
other people there and so the response
is yes peter like more lens brother is
coming here there is a big inheritor
family we have to go like you have to
get to this portal we need to take off
as fast as we possibly can now at that
point you switch over to one degree
mountain in eastern europe right the
home of the high evolutionary and you
pick up with kane now here's the thing
about kane right kane ben reilly all
these guys so here's the thing about
this so back in the 1990s and we've
actually got these videos covered here
on the channel and they're part of the
spider-man playlist if you want to check
them out after this video but what you
had was a story called the clone saga
probably one of the most reviled stories
among spider-man fans right it's one of
those where it was just it was only
supposed to be like maybe a 12 or 13
issue series and they ended up expanding
it and it spanned like three years right
it was just it ballooned up to being
unnecessarily large but the overall gist
here is that kane and ben reilly were
clones of peter parker that were created
by the jackal and the idea was to
basically screw with the head of peter
to even convince him that he himself was
a clone and so the whole gift behind the
story was it was marvel asking us as the
reader which one of these guys is the
actual real peter parker because you
didn't know which one it was you didn't
know if it was been riley he didn't know
if it was kane and he didn't know if it
was peter parker uh again that's one of
the reasons why it wasn't very well
received but kane is just kind of here
as part of mount wondergore basically
keeping all the people here protected
and then he's met by damos who basically
begins the process of trying to kill him
and consume his energy now as he goes in
for the kill against kane that's when
you end up getting bruce banner from
earth 7105 who's not a hulk but he is a
spider-man the old man spider of earth 4
whose identity is never given to us and
then a few others you've of course got
gwen stacy spider-gwen who's here as
well and that as they're basically
trying to trying to protect kane and
then fight off damos you've got ben
riley who steps in right now this is the
spider-man of earth 94 so it's not the
main marvel universe version of peter
parker he's been recruited here by the
other members of the spider-man army so
that's why you have a ben reilly here
it's not the ben reilly just a ben
reilly from an alternate reality but for
the most part during this whole conflict
bruce banner from this alternate reality
is killed right where at least his back
is broken so they basically leave him
for dead there's nothing they can do and
in reality it's not really a kind of
coldness that leads them to do that it's
because it's just practicality right
that if they were to stay there and they
were to fight deimos they would lose
more than just one guy and so ultimately
it's one of those things where it's like
we can't sacrifice the entire team for
just one individual right like it sucks
we got to leave him behind but we do and
so what you end up getting is all these
guys going through this portal and then
showing up in central park in earth 13.
now earth 13 is probably one of the
coolest universes that you don't really
get a whole lot of exposition about
instead this is the story where peter
parker never lost the enigma force so
back in 1989 well really december of
1989 running into 1990 marvel had a
story called acts of vengeance and this
is basically a story where loki brought
together all the different villains or
at least the most popular villains of
marvel comics and then switched around
who they were going to fight and had
them fight against different heroes and
so during this time what you had was a
manifestation of the enigma force now
the enigma force is exactly what you
think it is right it's a super powerful
force of energy but we don't really know
much about it outside of the fact that
it basically comes from the microverse
right like literally a microscopic
universe inside the main marvel universe
but the overall gist here is that
whenever the enigma force appears it's
like the watcher showing up right like
it's a significant thing during the acts
of engine storyline the enigma force
possessed spider-man because it was on
the hunt for a person that it needed to
possess and it's one of those things
where the enigma force does that it'll
appear and then it'll bond to a person
and then a successive series of people
until it finally settles on a compatible
host peter parker happened to be one of
those and it was actually a really cool
thing there was one point where you
punch the incredible hulk like into
space it was amazing but basically earth
13 is a universe where peter never lost
the enigma force where he basically held
on to it seemingly even all the way up
to this point right he's just super
powerful now one of the things to know
is the enigma force has been shown to be
capable in different capacities over the
years so it's really inconsistent in
terms of its power level but a lot of
what's going on here is just hitting
peter parker exceedingly hard because
it's a lot to happen at one time
basically in a matter of what we could
probably attribute to being 20 minutes
or so he's met all these alternate
reality versions of himself including an
animated version of himself who's a pig
right it's cool to see ben riley again
an alternate reality version of himself
that basically never became or never got
rid of the enigma force and then while
all that's going on when he's asked the
question like like why you know what why
am i here right like why is this whole
big thing being assembled he's told
because the inheritors are here right
like one of the things he's told by
spider-man from earth 13 is that because
the enigma force is part and parcel to a
universe if he were to leave his
universe that he would basically lose
the power of the enigma force he would
just become a regular spider-man and
that's why earth 13 is a safe haven
because this guy is a cosmic character
and his argument is if the inheritors
were to show up here to this reality i
would obliterate them it would be it'd
be a fool's errand right it'd be a
suicide mission and that's why they use
this as a safe place but he says this
battle that's happening peter this war
with like all this stuff the inheritors
we have you here because you're our
secret weapon you're the greatest of us
all right you're the only one who's ever
faced against more lun and survived not
only that actually killed him a couple
times and then beyond that there's
actually a much bigger role that peter's
going to play as part of this great big
huge spider-verse event that's what i
say this fighter totems will be
explained but what we end up doing here
is switching over to an alternate
reality it's labeled as earth 610 for
those of you guys who read the original
spider-verse event you guys know it's
actually 16 10. why does 1610 matter
because ladies and gentlemen this
universe is home to what i consider to
be the greatest spider character ever
made in the history of marvel comics
none other than miles morales yes it is
and miles morales is about to have a
very very terrible experience because as
he is mourning the loss of his mother
rio morales because this takes place
right when his mom dies you've
immediately got the arrival of verna and
all of her hounds that just come pouring
in with the intention of killing miles
killing this reality's version of
jessica drew who's basically a clone of
peter parker consuming their energies
and walking away with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace